Le Café de l'espace des sciences
avec la revue Science Ouest, Paris.
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous, Bienvenue
au Café des sciences qui a la chance
d'être le premier événement, ce soir, de
ce nouveau café des Champs Libres
dont je remercie
sincèrement toute l'équipe
pour son accueil.
Voilà donc cet événement.
Cette rencontre même est organisée
par l'équipe de la rédaction
de Science Ouest
qui est le magazine de l'Espace
des sciences que vous connaissez
peut être.
Sinon, je vous invite à le découvrir
à l'issue de cette rencontre.
Voilà, c'est
un magazine de vulgarisation scientifique
qui présente la recherche
en train de se faire dans la région.
Il y a beaucoup de choses en Bretagne
qu'on
n'imagine même pas et
donc notre équipe rencontre chaque mois
différents scientifiques
pour parler de sujets diverses et variées.
Voilà, Vous pourrez d'ailleurs
découvrir le tout nouveau numéro
qui vient de sortir.
Donc c'est un sujet
pas très joyeux non plus sur le climat.
Mais c'est très important
d'en parler, comme vous le savez.
Et on s'est posé la question
de quels sont les effets
et quels seront les effets du
réchauffement climatique sur notre santé.
Donc,
je vous invite à le découvrir en sortant.
Mais ce soir,
ce n'est pas l'état de notre espèce
dont nous allons parler,
mais plutôt de celle des insectes,
ces petites bêtes dont on oublie
souvent l'importance.
Voilà pour cela,
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés.
Johan Van Barren,
vous êtes écologue et directrice
du laboratoire
éco bio à l'université de Rennes.
Et puis Cécile Le Lann, également écologue
dans le même laboratoire ou laboratoire
éco bio.
Donc nous,
nous vous avions rencontré toutes les deux
lorsque nous avions écrit notre dossier
sur les insectes qui disparaissent
en avril dernier.
Donc nous allons pouvoir discuter ensemble
de ce dont on avait parlé.
Et puis d'expliquer un peu les recherches
que vous menez dans votre laboratoire.
Alors, pour information, cette rencontre,
vous pouvez y participer.
C'est à dire que n'hésitez vraiment pas
à poser des questions
tout au long de l'échange.
Voilà, si vous voulez intervenir,
poser une question particulière,
il faut juste lever la main pour que
ma collègue puisse vous donner un micro
parce que l'événement est enregistré.
Donc, même si on peut s'entendre comme ça
à voix haute, c'est beaucoup plus.
Ce sera beaucoup plus agréable
pour les personnes qui écouteront
le podcast a posteriori.
Donc vraiment, n'hésitez pas à intervenir.
Levez la main comme ça, Nous,
on vous fait signe, on vous donne un micro
et vous pouvez intervenir
et on essaiera de vous répondre.
Voilà.
Alors pour commencer, j'aimerais
quand même rappeler que les insectes
représentent 85%
de la diversité animale de la planète.
Ainsi, je ne dis pas de bêtises
et des millions d'espèces
seraient encore à découvrir.
Donc c'est dire leur importance finalement
pour l'ensemble des écosystèmes.
Cependant,
les études démontrent vraiment que leur
qu'il y a un déclin ces dernières années
dans toutes les régions du monde, c'est ça
qui est partout, dans tous les milieux.
On voit un déclin
signalé
l'une ou l'autre, vous voulez ?
Oui, ce déclin là,
il est effectivement généralisé.
Mais il y a sûrement des milieux qui vont
être plus plus exposés que d'autres.
Mais bon, c'est qu'on vit maintenant sur.
On parle plus de la biosphère.
On parle de l'anthropocène.
Faire parce que effectivement
l'homme a un impact en fait sur
qui est global sur la planète terre.
Donc effectivement
tous les milieux sont sans toucher.
D'accord.
Alors justement, vous parlez de l'homme ?
La grande question finalement,
je pense qu'on se pose tous.
Que se passe t il ?
Johan vous nous aviez indiqué qu'il
y avait notamment.
Je me souviens de cette première cause.
Le massacre des zones forestières.
C'est la le plus grand problème,
même s'il est loin d'être le seul.
Est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus justement ?
Est ce que c'est vraiment
un milieu qui est dévasté et donc qui
qui impacte directement
les espèces d'insectes,
les zones forestières tropicales
dans ce cas là, parce que ce sont
des zones extrêmement riches,
extrêmement riche en biodiversité
et entre autres
en biodiversité,
qu'on ne connaît même pas encore.
Et il n'y a pas,
quand c'est la forêt coupée
d'un seul coup, d'un seul.
Il y a toutes les espèces de ce milieu là
qui qui disparaissent
extrêmement fortement
dans nos régions.
Là, la forêt a été coupée il y a beaucoup,
beaucoup plus longtemps et
est finalement
le nouveau milieu qui s'est créé
dans un premier temps a plutôt amené
à une diversification parce que on avait
un milieu homogène qui s'est diversifié.
Et plus les milieux sont diversifiés
en zone tempérée,
plus on a de biodiversité.
En zone
tropicale, c'est la forêt tropicale
elle même
qui est déjà extrêmement diversifiée.
Et donc, si on la remplace par des champs
avec beaucoup d'insecticides, ça peut pas
donner de la diversité, quoi.
Ça c'est sûr.
Et alors, quand on détruit une forêt,
qu'est ce qui se passe finalement ?
Les espèces meurent,
elles ont plus du tout d'habitats.
Finalement,
qu'est ce qu'on sait sur l'impact,
sur les conséquences ?
En fait, sur les différentes espèces,
elles disparaissent ou elles s'en vont ?
Est ce que ou est ce qu'on ne sait pas ?
Oui, il y a
quelques espèces qui peuvent voler
au loin, même sur des grandes distances.
Ou il y a des espèces comme les pucerons
qui peuvent être emportées par le vent
sur des centaines de kilomètres.
Donc d'autres petits insectes aussi.
Mais tous ceux qui ont une capacité
de déplacement limitée
meurent sur place, évidemment.
En tout cas, de façon générale,
la destruction des habitats est
une des trois causes majoritaires
du déclin des insectes avec les pesticides
et le changement climatique aussi.
Donc la destruction
d'un habitat s'il n'y a pas,
parce que même s'il s'envole, on détruit,
il s'envole.
Encore faut il qu'il retrouve un habitat
acceptable ou identique dans les environs,
ce qui n'est pas garanti non plus.
Ainsi, bien sûr.
Et justement, vous parlez des pesticides,
Alors est ce que dans nos pays c'est
la première cause de ce déclin ?
Et quand je dis pesticides,
il y a peut être une distinction
aussi à faire entre les insecticides
et les autres produits qui aussi impactent
indirectement les espèces.
Oui, les insecticides, effectivement.
Après, on se pose quand même des questions
sur les autres substances chimiques.
Mais effectivement les pesticides.
Enfin les insecticides qui sont
directement dirigés sur les insectes
sont une des causes de déclin majeur
dans toutes les zones agricoles,
donc autour de chez nous, en particulier.
Vous vouliez rajouter quelque chose ?
Non, non sur les autres.
Les autres pesticides, effectivement,
on a déjà des informations
qui qui vont dans le sens
que ces molécules qui sont
par exemple des herbicides
ou des fongicides, soit pour supprimer
des plantes, soit
pour supprimer des champignons pathogènes,
peuvent effectivement
aussi avoir un rôle sur les insectes
et sur plein d'autres organismes.
D'ailleurs,
c'est pas simplement les insectes.
Donc effectivement, il n'y a pas
comme dit Johann, les insecticides
sont la molécule qui vise des insectes,
donc c'est normal qu'elle tue.
Elles sont des,
elles sont formées pour ça.
Mais effectivement, les autres pesticides
peuvent également jouer un rôle.
Ça peut être un rôle indirect
parce que on a une doctorante
qui a terminé sa thèse récemment
et qui montrait que
les plantes adventices,
donc ce qu'on appelle les mauvaises herbes
en règle générale
qu'on tue avec des herbicides,
sont capital pour les espèces d'abeilles.
Pas l'abeille domestique obligatoirement,
mais toute une gamme d'espèces
d'abeilles solitaires qui en fait
se développent sur les adventices.
Donc, a fortiori, les herbicides,
indirectement,
affectent énormément d'espèces d'insectes
et les affectent,
j'imagine sur des générations générations.
C'est pour cela que ce déclin
est très visible aujourd'hui,
alors que si ça perd leur habitat, s'il
n'y a plus d'adventices,
il n'y a plus aucun habitat
pour les abeilles solitaires.
Donc il n'y a plus d'abeilles solitaires.
Et effectivement,
il y a aussi des effets physiologiques
qui peuvent, qui peuvent eux aussi
perdurer sur plusieurs générations.
Donc en fait, c'est de manière d'action.
En fait,
de ces produits là, ce soit directement
en affectant la physiologie des insectes.
Donc ça peut modifier tout un tas
de composés essentiels en fait,
dont ils ont besoin pour vivre,
et donc ça affecte leur fécondité,
ça affecte leur longévité, et cetera.
Et puis, comme dit.
Si on détruit en fait leur habitat
ou leur source de nourriture,
ça peut les affecter directement.
Est ce
que même pour les abeilles domestiques,
il y a beaucoup d'apiculteurs
qui disent que la ressource disponible
en nectar n'est pas constante
au cours de l'année ?
Et puis, il y a des mois où les abeilles
sont en manque de nourriture.
Ça, ça a été prouvé
pour les abeilles domestiques.
Mais ça veut dire que c'est la même chose
pour les abeilles sauvages.
Il n'y a plus assez de fleurs
dans l'environnement,
pas assez de nectar dans l'environnement.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
N'hésitez pas.
La première est toujours difficile.
On va vous donner un micro, monsieur
ma collègue.
J'arrive.
Oui, oui,
oui, oui, oui, ça, c'est
un état des lieux qui est bien connu.
Mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait ? On va en parler ?
Oui. Alors oui, j'ai une petite idée,
On va y répondre.
Je pense que ça va quand même être
l'ouverture qu'on va essayer de répondre.
Par rapport à la retiens,
Vous arrêtez si j'oublie.
Par rapport au produit,
est ce qu'il y a des doses qui sont là ?
On sait qu'il y a des réglementations,
bien sûr, qui sont peut être à revoir.
Mais en tout cas, est ce qu'il
y a des doses qui peuvent être finalement
qui ne vont pas être forcément létales,
mais qui vont avoir des impacts
très, très importants malgré tout ça ?
Est ce que c'est une question de douze ?
Donc c'est assez connu.
Déjà que effectivement, de
par l'usage de ces pesticides
qui sont créés dans un premier lieu
pour agir en fait sur des organismes
qu'on souhaite cibler.
Donc par exemple des insectes
qui ravagent des cultures.
Donc on va appliquer des insecticides.
Donc on sait déjà qu'on a eu des problèmes
en fait pour pas mal de ravageurs
ou en fait
on a un contournement de la molécule.
Il va y avoir des résistances
qui se mettent en place.
Donc on sait que durablement,
pour plusieurs espèces d'insectes
qui peuvent devenir résistants
à ces insecticides et qu'au bout
d'un moment donné, en fait, ces molécules
ne sont plus efficaces et donc qu'il faut
effectivement trouver d'autres molécules
pour les remplacer.
Donc en terme de durabilité aussi, ça pose
un problème parce qu'il faut réinventer.
Et effectivement, on a aussi montré.
Enfin, il y a des travaux qui montrent
qui montre ça, qu'on a aussi tout ce qu'on
appelle des effets sur les taux.
Donc, c'est à dire
que même à des doses infimes
comme les pesticides, on va les retrouver
un peu partout dans l'environnement.
Donc, même s'ils sont appliqués
sur les parcelles du fait du ruissellement
hyper pluie de la dérive, même
quand ils sont aspergés sur une parcelle,
ça dérive forcément avec le vent Aussi,
sur les parcelles qui sont pas
les parcelles qui ne sont pas forcément
des cultures, des et des boisements
ou des habitations.
Il y a eu tout un tas de problématiques
autour de ça
et donc on sait que même
quand ils sont trouvés a des quantités
qui ne sont pas celles des doses
d'application de champ,
mais des doses plus infimes,
et on peut avoir aussi des effets létaux.
En fait sur ces insectes et donc ça
ça peut affecter leur comportement,
donc la manière dont ils vont se déplacer
dans l'environnement.
Donc par exemple, pour un pollinisateur,
ça peut perturber en fait sa capacité
à trouver des ressources florales.
Ça va affecter le nombre de descendants
qui vont pouvoir produire.
Voilà.
Donc ça peut avoir plein de conséquences,
même si ça tue pas directement,
Il n'y a pas forcément d'effet
direct sur la mortalité,
mais ça peut avoir des effets et qui
peuvent perdurer sur plusieurs générations
et ça, c'est des choses que vous étudiez
au laboratoire.
C'est c'est des pesticides notamment ?
Oui, c'est aussi des problématiques
qu'on a dans le laboratoire.
Donc on a justement une thèse
qui vient de démarrer il y a enfin
qui a démarré il y a un an et qui vise à
justement essayer de quantifier
ces pesticides
dans des milieux qui sont adjacents
à des parcelles agricoles.
En l'occurrence, c'est simplement des
des bandes qui sont enherbés
et qui sont aussi des refuges
de biodiversité pour plein
d'autres insectes
qu'on ne souhaite pas éliminer en fait
dans ces milieux agricoles,
et on essaie de comprendre
comment ils peuvent être aussi exposés,
comment ça les affecte.
Voilà.
À différents niveaux.
Est ce que
le secteur de l'agriculture
est le principal concerné par ce déclin
pour finalement parler de destruction
des habitats ?
Je ne veux pas du tout
jeter la perte d'agriculteurs.
Non, non, pas du tout.
Mais est ce que c'est
un secteur qui finalement,
si on a des changements, on pourra parler
peut être de solutions.
Est ce que déjà là, c'est vraiment
le gros terrain où il faut travailler,
où il faut avancer
pour pouvoir éviter la catastrophe ?
En fait, les insectes disparaissent
dans tous les milieux, en ville aussi.
En zone agricole aussi.
Il n'y a pas un c'est général.
Oui, c'est générateur, mais c'est général,
mais c'est extrêmement.
Il y a des espèces, par contre,
qui sont des espèces envahissantes et qui,
elles, progressent.
Donc c'est très inégal.
D'une espèce à l'autre.
Et en fait, on a extrêmement peu d'études
pour pouvoir dire les insectes déclinent.
Il faudrait déjà étudier dans un milieu
donné.
Par exemple, comment c'était
il y a 30 ans, commencer maintenant
et exactement au même endroit,
et puis sur toutes les espèces.
Ou quand on dit les insectes, c'est
une grande quantité d'insectes.
Donc ça veut dire que parmi tous celles
là, il y en a qui ont augmenté.
Un a baissé, il y en a qui ont disparu.
Voilà, c'est très.
Donc ça, c'est assez difficile.
Et en plus, le plus souvent, ça n'a
pas été forcément évalué il y a 30 ans.
Donc c'est assez difficile de dire
précisément
tel milieu ou tel endroit ou tel.
Il y a des petites tendances ou avant,
il y a des choses, mais c'est quand même
assez difficile de dire.
Par contre,
en milieu agricole,
peut être que c'est un milieu
où les insectes ont été beaucoup détruits
avec la découverte des pesticides.
Mais c'est aussi un milieu où, justement,
il y a des solutions à mettre en place et
et où on peut faire quelque chose.
Donc finalement, c'est très très difficile
de mesurer ce déclin, de le quantifier
comme vous expliquez ?
Oui, parce qu'il faut savoir effectivement
ce qu'il y avait avant et faire.
Il y a quelques études
qui sont faites beaucoup
sur les plantes pour montrer l'évolution
parce que finalement, en fait,
déterminer des plantes
ne veut pas que ce soit facile, mais.
Mais voilà, c'est un niveau,
on va dire faisable.
Il y a des études qui ont été faites
il y a 30, 40, même 60 ans dans la région
et qui sont d'ailleurs récupérées
par des chercheurs de notre laboratoire.
Actuellement, ils refont les mêmes points
d'échantillonnage et ils voient
effectivement, ils regardent un petit peu
l'évolution de cette végétation.
Mais pour les insectes, en fait,
il y a plein de familles différentes.
Ça exige pour
pas mal d'espèces de les observer
très finement sous une loupe,
d'aller voir des critères précis.
C'est très consommateur de temps.
Enfin, ça prend beaucoup de temps
de faire cette détermination
et donc on n'a pas forcément eu ces études
ou encore accès à ces données là
parce que des fois, ça peut arriver aussi
quand il y a eu des études. Mais
on n'a pas forcément encore les données
et donc de pouvoir les appliquer.
Voilà 30 ans après, on n'est pas forcément
toujours en capacité de le faire.
Ça se fait sur certains milieux
et ça a été fait.
Et donc ces études qui sont sorties
notamment en milieu agricole
où ils ont pu montrer
en fait une évolution au même endroit.
Il y a un déclin des insectes, ces études
allemandes qui sont sorties sur le sujet.
Mais ce n'est pas toujours facile à faire.
Et comme disait Johan,
il y a certains milieux
où on va avoir aussi une augmentation
des populations d'insectes.
Donc ce n'est pas toujours un déclin.
Donc en fait, quand on parle de déclin,
on peut l'observer dans certains milieux
en particulier,
on peut donner une tendance générale.
Mais ce n'est pas vrai
pour tous les milieux et c'est pas vrai
pour toutes les espèces.
C'est beaucoup plus complexe
qu'on ne le croit.
Oui, oui, même
cet été là, j'ai été
questionné plusieurs fois sur
une forte abondance de guêpes
que plusieurs personnes ont sans doute
remarqué.
Bon, voilà, ça peut être, même s'il
y a un déclin général des guêpes.
Ponctuellement cette année,
il y a pu se produire
un événement climatique particulier qui
a favorisé une forte émergence de guêpes.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
y en aura beaucoup l'année prochaine
et ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles
ne soient pas quand même en déclin.
De façon générale.
C'est
un peu comme les fruits dans un jardin,
pas dans mon jardin, il y a trois.
Depuis trois ans, on n'a pas de figues
et cette année, on en a beaucoup.
Parce que cette année, il n'a pas gelé
juste au moment.
Et donc exactement pareil
pour les populations de guêpes.
Et cette année, la succession d'événements
climatiques leur ont été favorables.
Mais et donc on en a vu beaucoup.
Mais mais voilà,
ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles sont pas
et peut être localisées.
Voilà, et ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles
ne peuvent pas être quand même en déclin
sur une tendance sur 20 ans.
En quoi c'est intéressant ?
Parce que c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait se dire on,
on le voit, on le voit plus
justement sur le pare brise.
On va beaucoup moins d'insectes.
Mais finalement, c'est aussi
un faux ami de se faire
une fausse idée, de se dire Ah ben là,
j'ai vu beaucoup de cette espèce.
Celle là, elle va bien.
C'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça.
Il y avait une question, Monsieur, si
on va vous donner un micro.
Un. Bonsoir, je m'appelle Didier
Chapelon, je suis adjoint
à la maire en charge de la biodiversité.
Voilà, donc ce sont des thématiques
qui m'intéressent et puis qui intéresse
de plus en plus de gens et d'urbains
en particulier.
Et moi, la question que je voulais vous
poser, c'est
si vous avez des éléments particuliers
sur le milieu qu'est justement la ville.
Voilà, c'est parfait.
Une très belle transition.
Vous l'avez évoqué y Joanne en plus,
ce milieu là qui est particulier.
Alors on parlait des pesticides.
Il y a plusieurs villes,
en tout cas en France,
et c'est le cas de la ville de Rennes
où on est sur le zéro pesticide.
On a peut être pas encore assez de recul.
Je ne sais pas si vous en avez.
Si effectivement, on observe
des espèces particulières qui vont mieux.
Voilà quel était l'effet.
Quel est l'effet de ce zéro pesticide ?
Si on
a suffisamment de recul, là,
on est vraiment
localisé sur sur du milieu urbain
et rennes éventuellement en particulier.
Si vous avez des éléments là dessus.
Merci, merci.
Du coup, effectivement,
dans toutes ces villes
où il y a zéro phyto et en fait Rennes
fait partie des premières villes en fait
à avoir été dans cette situation là
et à avoir fait aussi la différenciation.
La gestion des espaces verts
en laissant beaucoup de zones.
Ça, c'est.
Voilà, c'est deux choses
très intéressantes, très intéressantes.
Et bien je pense.
Je pense qu'à Rennes,
effectivement on peut.
Ça fait partie des villes
qu'on va qualifier
potentiellement
comme refuges de biodiversité par rapport
à des milieux agricoles
qui sont plus exposés à ces pesticides
ou conduites de manière plus intensive
aussi, donc avec des milieux
beaucoup moins diversifiés.
Donc, potentiellement, même en ville,
on peut trouver en fait des espèces qu'on
trouve moins en fait,
dans ces milieux
périurbains ou plus plus à la campagne.
Donc voilà, ça dépend de la ville, ça
dépend des pratiques qui sont conduites.
Et effectivement,
le zéro pesticide est un atout
pour pouvoir préserver des insectes.
Mais comme le disait Johanne
très justement,
la gestion différenciée
est le fait d'avoir des ressources
florales
de faire de la fauche tardive par exemple.
Ça favorise aussi
des communautés de pollinisateurs.
Alors voilà, après, on n'a pas de recul
sur l'ensemble des insectes.
En fait, dans ces milieux urbains,
on sait que potentiellement
pour les pollinisateurs.
En fait,
ce type de conduite peut être favorable
et donc peut permettre d'avoir
même des abeilles solitaires
et sauvages qu'on trouve en ville,
et pas seulement de l'abeille domestique.
Et on a deux projets en cours.
Donc c'est un peu difficile
de vous répondre pour l'instant aussi.
Mais là, il y a un postdoc et une thèse
en cours sur les insectes en milieu urbain
et on espère qu'on aura quelques données
quand ça sera terminé.
Donc d'ici un an ou deux.
Ce qui est aussi
pour voir l'impact de ces pratiques,
il aurait fallu faire 1.0, c'est à dire
avoir ce qui est ce qu'il y avait
au moment où on a arrêté
et si on n'a pas fait ce point zéro,
c'est difficile de dire oui,
ça a augmenté ou pas.
Mais statistiquement, de tout ce
qu'on connaisse, ces deux actions
sont extrêmement favorables,
donc à la biodiversité en insectes
et donc à la biodiversité en oiseaux
et autres autres espèces.
Par contre,
ce qui est ce qui a déjà eu comme
comme travaux sur la ville de Rennes,
de par les chercheurs
aussi encore du laboratoire, c'est
comme il y a un gradient d'intensité
de gestion entre les parcs rennais
où tous les parcs
ne font pas le même type de gestion
parce qu'évidemment,
ils n'ont pas les mêmes usages,
ils accueillent pas le même public,
et cetera.
En comparant cette différence de gestion
entre les différents parcs,
on peut voir en fait les conséquences déjà
en termes de diversité, même végétale.
Et donc ça, ça a été montré
sur la ville de Rennes qu'effectivement
les parcs on a plus de gestion
différenciée, en fait tardive.
Voilà, ça c'est un effet
clair et marqué sur la diversité végétale
qu'on va y observer.
Donc on a plus de diversité
quand on fait ce type de pratique.
Et les effets positifs, du coup,
la comptent dans ce sens là,
ils peuvent être assez rapides.
Finalement.
Alors ça dépend peut être aussi
des espèces ou des milieux.
Oui, là, au moins, si on les plante,
ça se voit entre différents parcs.
Donc potentiellement, ça se voit
sur les plantes et on a plus de fleurs.
Ça va se voir aussi
potentiellement sur les insectes.
Donc ça, c'est des travaux qui vont,
qui sont en développement.
En fait, sur la ville de Rennes,
c'est en partenariat d'ailleurs
avec la Ville de Rennes et Rennes
Rennes Métropole.
On travaille beaucoup avec eux
dans le laboratoire, ne va pas
nous spécifiquement, mais plein d'autres
personnes du laboratoire.
Donc oui, mais en même temps,
ces actions positives à plus de pesticides
et plus de biodiversité végétale,
c'est bien.
Mais il y a le
changement climatique qui qui
a ça ?
On ne peut pas l'enrayer directement.
Donc c'est vrai
que la diversification des habitats,
le fait de laisser des herbes plus hautes.
Ça, nos travaux ont aussi montré
que quand la végétation est plus élevée,
ça crée quand même un microclimat,
un refuge pour les insectes.
Donc voilà, Mais bon, après,
c'est le changement climatique.
Ça donne des stress
pour les insectes réguliers
et beaucoup plus fréquents qu'auparavant.
Donc le zéro pesticide
et la diversification végétale,
ça va aider les insectes,
mais ça peut être contrecarré
par par par la nouvelle menace
qui pèse sur eux.
Et il y a aussi
une histoire de corridors écologiques.
C'est à dire ?
On voit là, dans un endroit,
on remet de la biodiversité,
mais il faut que les insectes
se trouvent à cet endroit là.
Et si la population a été détruite
sur une grande distance,
de là à ce que les populations reviennent,
ça implique qu'il
y a des corridors écologiques,
donc des des endroits où les insectes
peuvent passer
pour aller dans une zone
où ils existent encore.
Pour revenir dans une zone
où ils ont disparu qu'à un moment donné
et juste juste pour rester un tout
petit peu encore en ville.
Est ce que la pollution lumineuse aussi
peut être un problème ?
On parle de la gestion du paysage, mais
est ce que la pollution lumineuse aussi ?
Peut être
est ce que on est quand même éclairé ?
Très, même s'il
y a aussi des efforts qui sont enclenchés.
Est ce que est ce que ça c'est
quelque chose que vous étudiez aussi
au laboratoire ou d'autres scientifiques,
évidemment.
Alors la pollution lumineuse ?
Allez, je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit étudiée sur les insectes.
Elle a pu être ici, il y a eu,
il y a eu quand même quelques études.
Ça pose problème,
non pas au labo, mais bien au laboratoire.
Oui, je sais, mais par contre,
il y a plein d'études sur le sujet.
Mais oui, c'est un gros problème
pour les insectes, entre autres.
Par exemple.
Ce qu'on sait pour les papillons
ou des insectes
qui sont attirés par les lumières.
On sait qu'ils sont incapables
d'apprendre à éviter
ces sources lumineuses,
donc ils vont toujours être attirés,
même si je ne sais pas
si on crée des dispositifs expérimentaux
ou des papillons
pourrait se brûler un tout petit peu,
mais pas pas mourir et donc s'échapper
après le lendemain et y retourne.
Ils sont incapables de ne pas être attirés
par la lumière et donc tout.
Tous ces toutes ces lumières
sont des pièges pour eux
et qui persistent comme ça
sur des longues durées.
Donc ça c'est c'est
vraiment problématique.
Et pour des insectes du genre ver luisant
qui communiquent avec ces lumière là,
ça empêche leur communication sexuelle,
donc ça empêche leur reproduction.
Donc ça, on sait que la lumière
est un problème pour les insectes.
Et on parle aussi maintenant
de ces corridors écologiques de zones
sombres pour permettre aux insectes
la trame noire.
Alors oui, ça existe des corridors
pour d'autres animaux ?
Oui, bien sûr, on parle des insectes,
mais effectivement, c'est pour eux.
Oui, il y avait une autre question
lui permet de revenir
juste un petit peu sur le thème précédent.
Pas de problème parce que ça permettrait
de répondre en partie au m.
Et puis de rebondir.
C'est la présence d'un élu.
On peut remercier des élus de s'intéresser
à la biodiversité.
Moi, j'interviens plutôt en tant que
urbaniste ici et je suis Rennais.
Donc il y a un petit,
il y a quand on a fait le zéro pesticide,
comme à Rennes ou dans d'autres villes,
il y a un trio qui doit fonctionner.
À mon avis,
c'est une décision de l'équipement
qui correspond
et de la formation à la pédagogie.
Donc ça, ça a bien marché.
On a appris aux Rennais
pourquoi il y aurait des herbes
un peu partout
et pourquoi c'est important qu'il n'y ait
pas de pesticides en formation.
Pédagogie, l'équipement.
Il faut des équipements plus mécaniques
pour désherber, voire
pas d'équipement
parce qu'on laisse pousser.
Et puis la décision, c'est souvent vous,
les élus, qui l'avaient prise.
Mais des fois, c'est aussi
le réseau associatif
ou l'écoute du réseau associatif
par les élus pour prendre une décision.
Et là, qu'est ce qui manque comme un avis
pour faire Biotop ?
En ville notamment,
on parlait des prairies plutôt au gazon.
C'est c'est ce trio qui n'a pas fonctionné
parce que,
par exemple,
on a un exemple très clair ici.
Derrière, on a, on a du gazon.
On peut se poser la question
pourquoi du gazon et pas de la prairie ?
Après le confinement,
en ce qui a été très beau, c'est
qu'il y a eu du biotope partout
parce que les prés
et les gazons
étaient devenus des prairies.
Ça a été génial.
On s'est tous dit plus comme avant,
c'est trop beau.
Et puis qu'est ce qu'on a fait ?
On s'est remis à tondre, à attendre,
attendre et à tuer le biotope
et à faire du gazon. Et pourquoi ?
Parce que le trio n'a pas fonctionné.
La décision n'est pas réellement prise.
Ça ne s'est pas opérée
comme pour les pesticides.
L'équipement.
Tant qu'on aura que des tondeuses
et pas des barres de fauche.
Dès que ça dépasse 30 cm,
on fait un broyat immonde.
Et les tondeuses, surtout Les machines,
peuvent pas emmener le broyat.
Donc on s'excuse
de laisser pousser un petit peu,
mais on tond quand même
parce qu'on n'a pas l'équipement.
Donc ça, c'est un problème.
Il faut plutôt s'équiper
en barres de fauche
et faire des robots de plage ou autres.
Mais où on peut enlever,
mais l'équipement ne nuit pas
et donc la formation Et la pédagogie
n'a pas suivi non plus.
Parce que dans les espaces verts,
ils n'ont pas l'habitude
de la prairie, de la fauche tardive.
Et puis on préfère, c'est un réflexe.
Le gazon nous va bien
et c'est un vieux réflexe qui date
du Moyen Âge, du temps de l'aristocratie.
Donc, ce trio, aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas tellement enclenché
pour faire Biotop en ville,
mais ça tient à peu de choses
parce qu'on est tous convaincus
que c'est vrai et que c'est important.
Donc je ne sais pas comment on peut
enclencher ça.
Urbaniste et élu technicien dans les
espaces verts et ça tient à peu de choses.
On est à deux doigts.
C'est dire. On est tous d'accord.
Mais comment on enclenche ça ?
Il y a des frais d'équipement au départ ?
Effectivement.
Si on doit changer des changements
de pratiques, ça prend toujours du temps.
Et mais en fait, la solution pour.
Pour redonner vie aux insectes,
en tout cas pour protéger les insectes
et, entre autres, de les protéger
aussi, des changements climatiques
qui leur tombent dessus autant que nous.
C'est vraiment la réintroduire
de la biodiversité végétale.
Donc c'est ça,
ce sont des théories écologiques
qui qui le disent, qui le montrent
à tous les endroits où ça a été fait.
Plus il y a de biodiversité végétale,
plus on aura de biodiversité en insectes.
Et donc, et ça,
chacun peut le faire, chacun peut agir
même sur son balcon, avec
quelques pots ou pas partout,
on peut, on peut le faire.
Et au niveau d'une ville, les espaces
où on peut le faire, que ce soit
les ronds points,
les trottoirs, les toits.
Si on commence
à faire des toits végétalisés,
mais aussi à remplacer les pelouses
rase et uniformes
par des endroits riches
en biodiversité végétale.
À terme, forcément,
ça va aider les insectes et ça va
pouvoir en faire revenir.
Pas forcément
les mêmes populations qu'il y a 50 ans,
mais il y en aura qui reviendront.
Et puis, c'est aussi une solution
qui peut être bénéfique aussi pour nous,
pour éviter les îlots de chaleur qui sont
on va laisser.
C'est quelque chose de très vertueux
qui peut aller que dans un sens,
la végétation, elle va.
Elle va être intéressante
à différents niveaux.
Dans ce que Joël a expliqué
tout à l'heure, c'est qu'effectivement,
dès qu'on a du couvert de la végétation,
et ça, on peut s'en rendre compte.
En fait,
quand on est en ville ou quand on sort
un petit peu de l'extérieur de ville
et on le voit
même à l'échelle de la ville rennaise,
il y a des capteurs de température
qu'on peut suivre en direct.
Il y a des zones
qui sont beaucoup plus végétalisées.
Là, notamment, il y a.
On peut voir les îlots de chaleur urbain
et on peut voir en fait les zones
où il y a la coulée verte,
les prairies Saint-Martin.
Sur le campus, vous êtes bien aussi.
Voilà qu'on c'est plus plus végétalisé.
Mais donc ça, on peut le voir directement.
Ça a un effet sur la température.
Donc que ce soit pour l'homme,
effectivement, pour les insectes,
ça fait un reflux
qui est un petit peu plus frais.
Et donc forcément, ça, ça tamponne en fait
l'effet des températures plus fortes.
Mais ça a aussi effectivement un rôle
d'habitats refuges.
Donc c'est des zones
pour la ponte de ces insectes.
C'est des zones
aussi d'alimentation pour ces insectes.
Et donc qui dit un sac dit aussi
bien effet sur les réseaux trophiques.
Parce que ces insectes, ils sont consommés
par tout un tas d'organismes,
des oiseaux,
des chauves souris, des mammifères.
Donc forcément,
ça fait un effet cascade
en réseau aussi
pour la biodiversité de manière générale.
Après,
ce n'est pas toujours si simple que ça
d'implémenter ces mesures là,
parce qu'on on.
Il y a aussi des effets liés à des
à la biodiversité.
En fait, en milieu urbain,
il y a tout un tas d'études au niveau
plutôt sociologique des deux.
Aussi.
Là, comment arriver à concilier
biodiversité et aussi sécurité en ville ?
Donc il y a tout un tout
un tas de choses en fait,
qui peuvent découler du fait qu'on peut
laisser en fait des espaces un peu plus
végétalisés ou moins tondre et tout ça
et qui peuvent être liés à la sécurité.
Alors soit ça peut même aller
jusqu'à de la criminalité
parce que quand on a des zones
plus fermées, une végétation plus cachée
potentiellement,
quand plus on éteint les lumières
pour faire la mort,
ça peut générer des problèmes.
Ça peut aussi être dû simplement à des
feuilles qui sont laissées par exemple.
Et puis c'est plus glissant.
Donc il y a des solutions à tout ça.
Mais ça veut dire qu'il y a.
Il y a un raisonnement en fait,
qui va au delà de ce dire
on peut le faire, on sait le faire, c'est
juste de l'équipement.
Ben non pas,
c'est pas juste ça, mais par contre
il y a des moyens de le mettre en œuvre.
Effectivement, il y a vraiment
un équilibre à trouver pour pour chaque,
chaque facteur
de pédagogie et de formation.
Oui également, bien sûr.
Bien sûr, vous avez raison. Oui,
pédagogie et formation à tous les niveaux.
Parce qu'il faut,
il faut vraiment que
là, c'est vrai que maintenant nos enfants
sont quand même beaucoup trop
enfermés à la maison.
Ils ne connaissent pas la biodiversité.
Les insectes en général,
ça a une une connotation négative.
Les araignées,
c'est toujours mal vu tous ces choses là.
Donc il faut, il faut redonner
la curiosité aux enfants dès le départ.
Je suis là, bien
qu'il y ait dans chaque école
un petit morceau de potager,
quelque chose comme ça que les enfants
examinent en fin les regarde des plantes,
les insectes et autres
pour ne pas en avoir peur. Pour
pas un oui, pour les qu'on aime
et on connaît.
Enfin,
on aime et on protège ce qu'on connaît.
Et là, la biodiversité en ville et
ailleurs, c'est quelque chose d'inconnu.
Les enfants connaissent bien les requins,
les baleines font des choses
loin, lointaines.
Mais ce qu'il y a juste chez nous,
la plupart ne connaissent pas,
même les petits oiseaux des jardins
ou euh,
qui comprennent
que les oiseaux des jardins,
ils vont pas survivre s'il
n'y a pas quelques araignées,
quelques quelques guêpes,
quelques moustiques.
Les hirondelles, ça ne survit pas
s'il n'y a pas des moustiques.
Mais bon, voilà,
il y a des choses quand même
du point de vue éducatif,
à vraiment revoir.
On s'est vraiment éloigné de la nature
et comprendre aussi
la fragilité, peut être des insectes
face au changement climatique.
Parce que, en fait,
les insectes sont l'ectoderme.
Ça veut dire que leur corps
et a la même température que l'air.
Ils n'ont pas de moyens de réguler
leur température comme comme nous.
Comme nous, comme certains hommes,
comme les oiseaux et.
Donc une vague de chaleur
peut beaucoup plus facilement les tuer.
Leur seul moyen de se protéger, c'est
d'avoir des refuges climatiques,
donc des endroits un peu plus frais.
Et ce qui est particulièrement gênant
en ville par rapport
à la campagne,
c'est quand il y a des vagues de chaleur.
C'est le fait que la température
ne redescende pas la nuit.
Donc c'est vraiment
les îlots de chaleur urbaine
à cause du bétonnage,
la le tout toutes les zones
bétonnées, la VONT vont décharger
de la chaleur pendant la nuit
et on a fait beaucoup d'études
sur les insectes dans notre laboratoire
qui montrent que si on expose des insectes
à une vague de chaleur
à un moment dans la journée, si la nuit
ils peuvent récupérer
par des températures plus fraîches,
ensuite ils peuvent survivre. Mais
si la nuit, ils peuvent pas récupérer, là,
ils sont très rapidement éliminés.
Un C'est le cas aussi
pour pour l'être humain.
On dit aussi que nous,
si on a besoin d'avoir
des températures plus fraîches la nuit.
Mais c'est encore plus vrai
pour pour les insectes.
Et ça a été totalement démontré que
s'il n'y a pas de fraîcheur nocturne, il
disparaissent très rapidement.
Alors justement, les effets
du réchauffement climatique, parlons en.
Cécile, C'est ce que vous étudiez ?
Vous étudiez vraiment cette question
là ? Oui.
Est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus des expériences
que vous menez au laboratoire
et peut être sur le terrain ?
Oui. Alors on travaille ensemble.
Donc j'ai posé la question.
Vous êtes sur le même schéma ? Oui.
Donc ça fait.
Ça fait un petit moment qu'on travaille
sur ce type de thématiques, donc
ça peut aller d'étudier
en fait la réponse des insectes face
à des vagues de chaleur ou des vagues
de froid qu'on peut mimer en laboratoire.
Donc là,
c'est vraiment de l'expérimentation.
On va essayer de comprendre en fait
comment ça peut s'appliquer, affecter
à la fois sur leur mortalité,
mais sur tous ces effets, aussi
sur le plus long terme.
Et on travaille essentiellement
dans les milieux agricoles,
donc sur des insectes,
des pucerons en l'occurrence en fait,
qui vont ravager des cultures de céréales,
soit de betterave,
tout un tas de cultures.
Et on travaille aussi sur des insectes
qui sont dits des auxiliaires de culture
qui vont consommer des pucerons
ou se développer
dans les pucerons pour les éliminer.
Donc on travaille à différents
avec différents types d'insectes.
Et effectivement,
on a conduit des études aussi
parce que là,
on a du recul dans ces milieux là,
on fait des échantillonnages
depuis longtemps et effectivement,
on a pu montrer en fait qu'on
avait un changement dans les abondances
de ces insectes, que ce soit les pucerons,
que ce soit leurs leurs ennemis
naturels,
notamment due au réchauffement des hivers.
Donc en milieu tempéré,
on voit qu'il y en a des espèces
qu'on ne trouvait pas en hiver avant
et qui vont être présentes maintenant.
On sait que maintenant les
pucerons,
ils vont aussi se reproduire tout l'hiver.
Donc ces pucerons,
comme ils sont potentiellement porteurs
de maladies
qui sont néfastes pour les plantes,
ça peut conduire à
de la réémergence de certaines maladies.
Et puis, la question de se poser aussi
comment on fait pour lutter
contre ces ravageurs
dans un contexte aussi où On interdit
en fait l'usage de certains pesticides
comme les néonicotinoïdes ?
Donc, il faut trouver des alternatives
à tout ça
et donc ça fait partie des solutions
comme ça.
Ça peut enchaîner directement là dessus
avec Johann, ce sur quoi
on a beaucoup travaillé, c'est notamment
cette manipulation de la diversité
dans ces milieux agricoles.
Donc de travailler à la fois sur
quelles limites ?
En fait, on peut s'imposer à l'échelle
des parcelles.
Est ce qu'on doit vraiment détruire
toutes les Aventis ?
Est ce qu'on ne peut pas en garder
certaines
sans que ce soit néfaste pour la culture ?
Parce qu'il
faut toujours être dans une objectif aussi
de se dire qu'on
va quand même produire tout ça ?
C'est important
de conserver aussi
la diversité de plantes sauvages
autour aussi des parcelles.
Ça commence à être vraiment bien connu.
Il y a des travaux sur le sujet déjà
depuis au moins 20 ans maintenant
qui montrent qu'effectivement
les milieux agricoles, quand il n'y
a plus de haies, plus de boisement,
qu'on laisse des bords de champ
un peu préservés
et non traités aux pesticides,
on favorise aussi bien plus d'ennemis
naturels, des ravageurs des cultures.
Et donc on arrive aussi à avoir
un meilleur contrôle de ces ravageurs.
Donc Ça, c'est des choses qu'on peut faire
et on peut aussi manipuler
la diversité cultivée.
Donc on peut jouer sur des variétés
qui vont un mélange de variétés plutôt
que d'avoir un seul type de variétés.
D'ailleurs,
ça peut aussi permettre de répondre
aussi aux problématiques
du changement climatique,
donc d'avoir des variétés qui peuvent être
plus ou moins résistantes à la sécheresse
et aussi plus ou moins résistantes
aux attaques de ces ravageurs.
Donc voilà
donc on nous, on a travaillé pas mal
sur l'utilisation de couvert
fleuri notamment et parce que justement,
il apporte des refuges climatiques,
des refuges en nourriture.
Et on a pu montrer qu'effectivement,
quand on amène, on fait
des couverts fleuris à proximité
de nos parcelles de céréales.
Là, on est en train de répliquer
la même chose sur les betteraves.
La problématique de l'interdiction
des néonicotinoïdes
et on a pu montrer qu'on arrivait
à réduire de façon conséquente en fait
les populations de pucerons de 40%
juste en plaçant
un couvert fleuri à côté de la parcelle.
Et pas ça, on a, on augmente
les ennemis naturels qui vont consommer
ces pucerons et on arrive également
à réduire en fait l'incidence des virus
qui sont véhiculés par ces pucerons,
également dans les plants.
Du coup,
c'est quand même assez prometteur.
Donc ce n'est pas le seul levier.
Comme je l'ai dit,
il y a plein d'autres éléments,
mais on peut essayer d'imaginer
facilement, en jouant sur les multiples
leviers, de pouvoir avoir une agriculture
peu plus durable
dans un contexte
où on a, on interdit en fait
de plus en plus ça, et c'est
l'objectif à terme de ne plus avoir de.
Et quand ?
Quand on parle de sauvegarder
les insectes, en fait, on est quand même
très conscients de certains insectes
qui sont nuisibles à l'activité humaine
et dont l'objectif,
c'est d'augmenter la biodiversité.
Mais maintenant
qu'on commence à comprendre beaucoup mieux
comment fonctionne telle et telle espèce
et les besoins de telle ou telle espèce,
L'objectif de nos recherches,
c'est quand même
de favoriser les insectes
qui sont utiles à l'homme.
Et puis essayer d'aménager l'environnement
de façon à défavoriser les insectes
qui sont réellement nuisibles,
entre autres, à nos cultures.
Il ne s'agit pas non plus de favoriser
l'ensemble des insectes de façon générale,
par exemple le moustique tigre
qui est en train de remonter.
On sait qu'il y a des choses
qui favorisent beaucoup son installation,
son maintien comme ha
d'avoir de l'eau stagnante
dans dans des pneus ou dans des récipients
ou des choses comme ça.
Et donc la connaissance de l'écologie
d'une espèce peut aussi
permettre
de limiter ces espèces nuisibles.
On est quand même conscient
qu'il y a des espèces qui posent problème
et donc ce qu'il faut essayer,
c'est de connaître bien les insectes,
de connaître leur comportement,
de connaître leurs besoins et de faire
ce qui favorise en particulier
les espèces qui nous aident,
qui donnent ce qu'on
appelle les services écosystémiques,
donc les services que la biodiversité
peut offrir à l'homme.
Donc voilà, là il y a des insectes
qui sont très utiles, entre autres
les pollinisateurs et des petits insectes
qu'on appelle des parasitoïdes
sur lesquels on travaille
et qui tuent par exemple
les pucerons dont beaucoup de personnes
veulent se débarrasser.
Et donc, pour favoriser ces deux
espèces d'insectes très utiles à l'homme.
On a montré que les plantes à fleurs,
c'était vraiment important
qu'il y ait toujours dans l'environnement
des fleurs et le changement climatique.
Effectivement, c'est très néfaste
avec les vagues de chaleur,
mais on peut aussi l'utiliser
parce que, par exemple,
les hivers réchauffent
et le fait que les hivers réchauffent.
Et ça permet à des plantes
d'être fleuri en hiver
et donc fournir pendant l'hiver
des plantes à fleurs aux insectes utiles.
Ça, c'est aussi quelque chose, une action
très bonne pour les protéger et pour
protéger spécifiquement les insectes qui
nous sont directement utiles.
Vous vouliez rajouter quelque chose ?
Non, Et juste dire que, en fait,
pour choisir les bonnes espèces de fleurs
et tout ça et avoir cette connaissance
fait, ça prend aussi du temps
parce qu'on s'amuse pas à installer
n'importe quoi.
On installe pas
par exemple des espèces exotiques
ou qui pourraient poser un problème,
être envahissant ou qui au contraire
pourraient favoriser les ravageurs.
Donc ce que disait Johann en fait,
c'est ça, c'est que ça.
On a besoin d'avoir de bonnes
connaissances de l'écologie générale,
des des insectes qu'on veut favoriser,
mais aussi des plantes qu'on va utiliser,
des conséquences qu'elles peuvent avoir
pour l'environnement.
Et donc, du coup, dans cette manipulation,
on essaie de raisonner l'ensemble
des maillons de la chaîne,
et pas parce qu'on sait bien
qu'il y a eu des erreurs liées
à de l'introduction d'organismes
qui peuvent poser problème par la suite,
que ce soit des plantes ou des insectes.
Donc là, l'idée, c'est de travailler
en fait sur une diversité végétale
même qui peut déjà être existante
en fait dans l'environnement,
et de voir ce qu'est ce qui peut optimiser
des populations qui sont déjà là,
des ennemis,
des pucerons qui sont déjà là.
En fait,
on essaie essentiellement
de travailler sur les espèces locales
et pas du tout d'introduire
des espèces nouvelles dans le système,
mais de ne pas éradiquer
des espèces locales
qui peuvent être utiles
aux insectes locaux.
Parce que là aussi, les insectes,
ceux qui
vivent ici, sont adaptés aux plantes
d'ici.
Donc rapporter des plantes exotiques,
ce n'est pas forcément ça.
Ça a peut être même pas d'utilité
pour les insectes locaux ou quoi.
Donc il faut vraiment retravailler
sur la biodiversité
locale, principalement
pour éviter les erreurs
qui ont été faites dans le passé.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions
et peut être rebondir sur. Non.
Moi, j'en avait une petite par rapport
aux bancs de Fleury.
C'est quelque chose qui se fait déjà.
C'est
une pratique que les agriculteurs ont.
Ouais, alors on a la chance
parce que Daren, dans le laboratoire
et avec d'autres laboratoires
partenaires rennais,
on travaille depuis très longtemps
en fait sur ce qu'on appelle notre zone
atelier qui est la zone atelier Armorique
qui est un site d'observation
à long terme.
Et donc on a des partenariats
depuis presque 30 à 40 ans
avec des agriculteurs de la région
avec lesquels on travaille.
Donc en fait, on commence à avoir
pas mal de recul et une habitude
en fait
de travailler avec les agriculteurs.
Et on a établi depuis plusieurs années
en fait
un mode de contact où on organise
en fait des repas avec eux.
C'est fermé, donc chaque année,
pour faire part des recherches
qui ont été fait sur leurs parcelles,
dans leur territoire.
Et eux, ils nous font part
aussi de leurs problématiques.
Donc, s'il y a de l'émergence
de nouveaux problèmes ou de choses
comme ça,
et donc en fait, on a ce dialogue où.
En fait, si on est en mesure d'y répondre
et qu'on est en capacité
à y répondre à chaque fois, on essaie
de répondre à leurs problématiques.
Donc du coup, l'installation
de ces bandes fleuries là
s'est fait de concert et s'est fait
dans les champs autour de Rennes,
donc avec un réseau d'agriculteurs
partenaires
qui sont des agriculteurs qui peuvent
d'ailleurs avoir tout type de pratiques.
Mais on sait pas vraiment.
C'est très vaste en fait ce réseau là,
avec des pratiques qui vont
de l'usage de zéro pesticide,
la conservation, pas de labours,
de beaucoup de
diversification à des usages
qui sont beaucoup plus,
on va dire de l'agriculture,
plus classique.
On peut appeler ça comme ça
ou plus conventionnel.
C'est ça le terme
qu'on utilise habituellement
avec plus usage de pesticides, du labour,
des rotations plus faibles et du coup,
chacun peut se peut se prêter aussi
au jeu de ce dispositif et en voir en fait
les retours bénéfiques
sur ses propres parcelles.
Vous parlez de formation, de pédagogie,
ça passe aussi avec eux.
C'est vraiment un travail commun,
Je pense, oui,
et ils ont aussi des initiatives
tout à fait
une chose
qu'ils essayent de vous apporter.
Voilà, On peut justement venir vérifier
en fait des initiatives qu'ils ont
pu avoir et voir si c'est quelque chose
qui peut marcher de manière plus globale
que les mesures de le faire.
Et donc, typiquement,
il expérimente également.
Il joue le rôle
d'un agriculteur chercheur.
J'avais un agriculteur qui disait ça
dernièrement dans un petit reportage
et je trouve ça très bien.
Et voilà.
Et donc où on travaille de concert
en fait sur des parcelles réelles.
Et puis j'imagine
qu'ils doivent être très demandeurs aussi.
Ils doivent être confrontés
à certaines problématiques
pour lesquelles vous avez
peut être pas toujours les réponses,
mais qui peuvent vous ouvrir
sur des axes de recherche.
Oui, et je pense que de plus en plus,
tout le monde, à sa manière, en fait,
peut se sentir concerné.
Et eux,
ils sont directement impactés aussi
par le fait qu'on doit réduire en fait
l'usage des pesticides.
Donc évidemment, ils sont en attente
de voir s'il
y a des solutions alternatives
qui pourrait fonctionner
et dans quelle mesure elles fonctionnent.
Donc ça, on est en mesure de leur dire
voilà, ça fonctionne, mais à ce niveau
là de 30%,
on peut réduire l'impact du tout.
On fait ça
par contre à associer à tel autre levier,
ça permet encore de réduire de temps.
Donc est ce que c'est
acceptable, acceptable
en terme de production, de rendements ?
Et donc on peut échanger
comme ça ensemble ? Oui,
en fait,
mettre des fleurs dans l'environnement
un peu partout.
De toute façon, ça,
ça peut être globalement que positif
pour augmenter la biodiversité
des insectes.
Par contre, si on est sur un problème
agricole de production économique
uniquement, mettre des fleurs, ça,
ça ne suffira pas.
Il faut associer ça.
On ne peut pas remplacer
d'un coup d'un seul les pesticides
par les fleurs et puis rien faire d'autre.
Quoi ?
C'est une combinaison de leviers,
c'est vraiment ça qui semble fonctionner.
C'est à la fois
le choix de certaines variétés,
à la fois de la surveillance
épidémiologique.
Elle va vraiment regarder où
la prophylaxie va surveiller,
les cultures de plus près
pour détecter les premières arrivées
de ravageurs
et en plus les bandes fleuries.
Et voilà,
on additionne toutes les techniques.
Et puis ça peut fonctionner,
mais il y a une question.
On se rend dans soit
Comment vous avez choisi ces parcelles
tests ?
Est ce qu'il
y a moyen de choisir en particulier
des périmètres de protection de captages
ou des aires d'alimentation,
de captage
d'eau potable ?
Je veux dire oui, oui,
donc ça dépend de nos problématiques.
En fait, c'est ces parcelles.
Elles peuvent être choisies
soit sur la base des pratiques agricoles,
pour voir si, par exemple,
notre effet de bande fleurie
peut être appliqué sur tout type
de parcelles en fonction
des différentes pratiques agricoles
qu'on peut avoir.
Donc justement, est ce qu'on traite ?
C'est ce qu'on traite pas ?
Est ce qu'on laboure, on laboure pas ?
Donc effectivement,
il y a aussi des études qui sont faites
justement pour savoir aussi, en fonction
des périmètres dans lequel on se trouve.
Donc c'est l'intérêt de cette zone
atelier aussi, c'est qu'on a des zones
dans le département de l'Ille et Vilaine
qui sont plus ou moins en fait conduites
en agriculture biologique, d'autres
plus en agriculture conventionnelle.
Et donc on peut avoir des zones
où on a des territoires avec beaucoup,
beaucoup de parcelles qui sont conduites
sans traitement ou des traitements
qui sont
homologués dans le cadre
de l'agriculture biologique.
Et puis des parcelles aussi
qui peuvent être plus avec de traitement.
Et donc ça, on est capable
via de l'analyse des paysages.
En fait, quasiment
tout est cartographié maintenant.
En fait, sur les zones agricoles,
on peut mesurer la distance
aux habitations.
On peut avoir une idée en fait de
si on fait des mesures de captation
de ces pesticides
soit dans les sols, soit dans l'eau du sol
ou soit plus en aérien.
Pour mesurer la dérive,
on peut mesurer en fait effectivement
ce qui pourrait être reçu
sur les zones habitables.
Donc ça, il y a des projets
qui sont en développement en laboratoire
pour avoir plus d'information là dessus.
Et puis sur l'eau, oui,
on a déjà des éléments.
On sait déjà qu'il y a une partie
en fait des pesticides
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver dans notre eau.
Et ça, c'est connu depuis longtemps.
Effectivement,
Et ce que je
voulais dire, c'est
est ce qu'on peut mêler
la recherche à de l'utile
pour faire de la recherche appliquée
et donc concentrer un peu
cette cette recherche sur des zones
où il serait souhaitable qui ait
le moins de pesticides possible, utilisés,
même si c'est de l'agriculture
conventionnelle à certains endroits.
Là, on vient de faire un projet
qui va commencer,
qui vient juste d'être accepté,
où On se focalise spécifiquement
sur les zones les plus intensives
pour essayer de convaincre
les agriculteurs de ramener
un peu de biodiversité dans ces zones là,
sans perte de rendement majeurs.
Donc, les recherches n'ont pas pour but
d'augmenter les rendements,
mais de montrer qu'on peut
sauvegarder un peu de biodiversité
sans perte de rendement.
Donc on a cette composante économique.
En tout cas, on demande aux agriculteurs
leur rendement dans nos projets.
On essaie d'avoir
des mesures de compensation,
c'est à dire
si ces agriculteurs sont volontaires pour.
Faire un essai et que cet essai va
engendrer des pertes.
On peut essayer d'avoir
des compensations pour les pousser
à au moins faire des essais.
Mais de toute façon,
à chaque fois,
il y a une question de recherche
et par exemple, pour une question donnée,
on va rechercher des des parcelles
avec par exemple
une haie d'un côté
et puis une bande herbeuse de l'autre.
Pour un autre essai,
on aura besoin de parcelles de blé,
par exemple avec une parcelle de maïs
qui est juste à côté.
Pour une autre question de recherche,
on aura besoin, je sais pas, à fin d'une
parcelle de céréales et ensuite
d'une
bande herbeuse et d'une rivière à côté.
Et donc après on, on fait appel,
on fait appel aux agriculteurs volontaires
qui ont la configuration
qu'on recherche pour faire l'expérience
qu'on veut réaliser.
Parce que le problème, c'est toujours.
Si on a une expérience scientifique,
il va toujours falloir qu'on puisse faire
au moins une dizaine de répétition
de la même chose.
Donc, on trouve dix parcelles
qui sont à peu près la même configuration
sur laquelle on peut faire le test
qu'on souhaite.
Ça, ce sera quelque chose d'important.
Mais oui, pour répondre à l'application
en fait, au niveau de la contamination
des cours d'eau, et je pense qu'en fait,
c'est toute la région qui est concernée.
Donc là, quel que soit l'endroit,
quand on pose
ce type de question, en fait,
on est dans la recherche appliquée.
Donc là, nous,
on a notre travail de chercheur.
On va apporter des réponses en mettant
en place un protocole scientifique.
Après, on a cette diffusion qu'on peut
avoir au niveau des agriculteurs.
On travaille aussi
avec les chambres d'agriculture,
avec différents partenaires.
Mais après, on n'est pas les décideurs.
Après, au final de ce qui va être
mis en place, on peut être.
On est là pour apporter du conseil et on
Mais ce n'est pas nous qui prendront
la décision finale de si telle mesure
va être appliquée à tel endroit.
Mais par contre, on a ce terrain de jeu
qui fait qu'on peut tester,
fait des dispositifs
et répondre à des questions de recherche
qui sont très appliquées. Oui
monsieur, si je peux me permettre.
En complément.
Donc, Jean-Baptiste Morisot,
dans son dernier livre
Raviver les braises du vivant, a fait
part de certaines certains d'études.
Justement, on peut constater déjà
que le biotope a disparu
de la plupart de nos campagnes.
Le remembrement y est pour beaucoup.
Mais en tant que vieux,
je me souviens, quand mes parents,
qui étaient de Poitiers,
on faisait la route à 4 h de voiture,
ont été obligés de s'arrêter à mi chemin
parce que le pare brise était
tellement tartiné d'insectes
qu'on était obligé de nettoyer.
Le pare brise s'est arrêté pour ça.
Aujourd'hui, c'est impensable.
Donc ce qu'a dit ce qu'a révélé
Baptiste Morisot dans son dernier livre,
c'est que 10% de réels biotopes
réintroduits dans les cultures,
donc la zone est très extractive.
Il peut reprendre son terme à condition
que ça fasse
ce que vous appelez tout à l'heure
le corridor écologique.
Quand les mailles 10%
de ce territoire suffit à rehausser
de façon très significative le niveau
de biodiversité et de rendre la chose
positive dans la zone agricole.
Parce qu'un équilibre se retrouve
donc, c'est pour être juste en complément,
pour préciser qu'il
y a des essais qui sont faits
et on sait déjà que ça peut fonctionner,
que 10% c'est quand même pas rien.
Et puis en plus il faut les mailler,
mais si on s'y prend, si on programme,
si on rentre les choses
dans un vrai programme, on va dire
à la fois d'agriculture et d'écologie.
Il y a plusieurs ministères qui doivent
se parler et ce n'est pas évident.
Mais comme ça, si on le décide
encore, on sait déjà,
on a des amorces d'études auxquelles vous
participez, qui montrent que c'est
totalement à notre portée.
Donc c'est un élément à la fois positif.
Là où on peut être pessimiste
et si personne ne veut l'entendre
et qu'on retourne
comme après le confinement
ou on continue à tendre
plutôt que de laisser les prairies,
Mais ça tient à peu de choses.
Je pense qu'il faut, il faut vraiment
qu'on sache à un moment se retrouver pour
pour passer à cette action là.
Il y a des transactions et en ville aussi.
Quoi faire ?
Local à bon milieu parce qu'il
y a quand même beaucoup moins de
de retombées économiques.
Réintroduire de la
biodiversité en ville, c'est
déjà tout le monde
peut y participer dans une moindre mesure,
et ce n'est pas forcément
extrêmement coûteux,
peut être un peu un investissement,
un changement d'habitudes.
Départ, mais, mais quand même.
Et ça,
il peut y avoir une implication réelle
des citoyens dans cette action.
C'est à dire donc l'action éducative
et peut être là très rapidement
parce que la ville, elle, appartient
à une énorme quantité de personnes.
Alors que dans les champs agricoles,
ça reste quand même quelques agriculteurs
qui ont des grandes parcelles.
Donc,
et ce qu'il faut aussi développer,
c'est beaucoup les sciences participatives
pour que les gens se sentent parties
prenantes de la chose.
Enfin, quand on voit, par exemple pour les
pins, pour la biodiversité, des actions
comme le fait comme Faune Bretagne.
Donc, c'est un site participatif
où chacun met ses observations,
que ce soit d'oiseaux,
de papillons, de libellules.
Enfin, ils ont plusieurs taxons
et comme ça,
les gens commencent à s'intéresser,
puis à regarder.
Et puis quand on s'intéresse, on connaît
et on voit qu'un tel endroit, il y a ça.
Puis bien, dans mon jardin, il n'y a pas.
Qu'est ce que je peux faire pour ?
Donc voilà,
c'est cette cette action là aussi
pour redonner vie aux insectes,
c'est que les gens s'y intéressent
et les regarde et les notes
et essaye de les y connaissent.
Et puis surtout qu'on est tous concernés.
Et en plus question tout à fait,
on va prendre une toute petite
dernière question.
Bonsoir !
Alors justement,
dans dans un but de sensibiliser les gens,
de les pousser à s'intéresser à tout ça,
aux insectes et aussi pour pousser
ceux qui prennent les décisions
à favoriser
leur diversité.
Est ce que vous pourriez
peut être nous définir
les principaux services écosystémiques
des insectes ?
Justement ?
Alors on a parlé en fait
de ces insectes
qui sont des auxiliaires des cultures,
par exemple en milieu agricole,
mais aussi en milieu urbain,
comme on a des insectes qui vont manger,
d'autres insectes
qui peuvent attaquer, des plantes
qui sont utiles à l'homme.
Effectivement, ça,
c'est le service de lutte biologique.
Donc ça le service de services
écosystémiques, là, il est très important.
Il est assuré
par beaucoup
d'insectes contre d'autres insectes.
Il est assuré aussi d'ailleurs
par aussi les oiseaux
aussi, les chauves souris et d'autres,
mais aussi les araignées,
les araignées aiment pas les oublier
comme font partie des arthropodes.
Et on a aussi,
bien sûr, le service de pollinisation.
On a une large proportion de nos cultures,
plus de 80% en fait,
qui ont besoin
d'être pollinisées, pollinisées par des
par des animaux.
En fait, pour se développer.
Et les insectes font partie des plus gros
pollinisateurs de ces cultures.
Donc là, évidemment,
si on veut avoir des légumes
et des fruits, il nous faut des insectes.
Qu'est ce qu'on a d'autre ?
On a des insectes qui vont décomposer
aussi recyclage de la matière organique.
Voilà donc qui vont être des décomposeurs.
Il y en a certains qui sont utilisés
en fait pour ces propriétés là, justement.
Même avec des essais
pour dégrader le plastique
parce qu'ils ont des capacités en fait
pour certains à pouvoir dégrader
en fait ces matériaux plastiques.
Donc la décomposition aussi
quelque chose d'important.
Est ce qu'on peut avoir d'autres ?
C'est les principes, on va dire,
c'est les principaux, On va dire major,
pollinisation,
lutte biologique et décomposition.
Voilà.
Et ils servent aussi pour l'humain.
Donc ça peut être
une base de l'alimentation humaine.
Donc on peut se nourrir d'insectes.
Et puis servent aussi à nourrir
en fait tout un tas d'autres.
D'autres animaux bien sûr.
Donc dans le fonctionnement,
même après des réseaux trophiques et
dans l'écosystème complet, les insectes
sont une source d'alimentation
et sont réfléchis d'ailleurs
comme étant une source d'alimentation
et une source de protéines potentielle
pour l'homme.
Donc on a tous intérêt à les chouchouter.
C'est intéressant parce que finalement,
ce que vous expliquez, c'est qu'il
y a quand même des solutions,
même si ça peut prendre du temps
à mettre en place, mais aussi
pour comprendre ces espèces
et leur leur fonctionnement.
Mais finalement, tout n'est pas perdu.
Il faut garder espoir.
Non, mais c'est important, je pense.
Aujourd'hui, tout n'est pas perdu.
Mais c'est surtout que chacun s'y mettre
et chacun peut agir à son niveau.
C'est ça aussi
qui est important et citoyen,
parce que ce qui est important,
c'est c'est vraiment l'aspect
corridors écologiques.
C'est vraiment que ces petites fleurs
qu'on met,
il y en ait partout
et pas que dans un petit endroit.
Et donc voilà,
il faut vraiment que chacun puisse agir
et que chacun commence à s'intéresser
en fait à toute cette vie là,
parce que c'est la connaissance
qui qui va nous permettre
d'avoir envie de faire quelque chose.
Et on peut chacun aussi,
avec les sciences participatives
sur des sites comme Faune Bretagne
ou naturalistes ou il y en a beaucoup.
On va mettre ces observations,
savoir ce que les autres observent
et donc participer à la connaissance.
Et est ce qu'à chaque fois,
pour parler de déclin,
on a besoin de savoir ce qu'il y avait
avant, ce qu'il y a après ?
Et ce n'est pas nous,
quelques scientifiques,
qui pouvons mesurer la biodiversité
qu'il y a partout.
Ça, c'est vraiment là.
Il faut que ça se fasse grande échelle.
Et comme ça,
on va pouvoir mesurer année après année.
Justement, on arrête les pesticides, là
va l'impact, on met des fleurs, là,
voilà l'impact.
Ça, ça implique que tout
le monde s'y mette dans la
date, dans la diffusion de la connaissance
et donc à prendre soi
même les grandes catégories.
Chaque année, par exemple le dernier week
end de janvier, pendant 1 h,
chacun peut compter les espèces
d'oiseaux familières dans son jardin.
Ça, c'est facile à faire.
Et si ce n'est pas dans son jardin,
le faire dans le parc public
le plus près de chez soi ou dans n'importe
quel parc public.
Et plus on a de données sur les oiseaux,
ça participe aussi aux données
qu'on peut avoir sur les insectes
parce que beaucoup d'espèces d'oiseaux
dépendent des insectes par exemple.
Donc, le déclin des insectes,
ça va aussi affecter le déclin des oiseaux
et ainsi de suite.
Donc il faut.
En fait, il faut que chacun s'intéresse
à la biodiversité.
On n'a pas besoin
de beaucoup de connaissances pour ça.
On n'a pas beaucoup de ça.
On n'a pas besoin de
beaucoup d'argent pour ça.
C'est
quelque chose qui est à la portée de tous.
Merci beaucoup.
C'est un très beau message
et j'en profite pour souligner que
que les cafés de l'Espace des sciences
sont organisés en partenariat avec l'UNIR.
Donc ils rassemble un bon nombre
d'établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et qui a pour projet
le projet de tissage dont vous aurez.
On pourrait regarder, il y a des
des plaquettes en fait
qui présentent ce projet et ce projet
vise vraiment à renforcer les liens
entre citoyens, chercheurs et décideurs.
Et je pense que l'échange,
les échanges que nous avons eus ce soir
illustre ce besoin aussi de dialogue
entre les différents acteurs pour qu'on
puisse aussi croire en l'avenir.
Je pense en tout cas
pour le fait de la science.
On a un stand à la fête de la ville.
Johanne, vous allez dire je vous écoute,
c'est dimanche
dans notre labo, fin
toute la semaine, notre labo éco bio
a plusieurs stands
pour la Fête de la science, dont un
sur la microbiologie,
un sur sur les vers de terre à Paimpont.
Mais sinon, il y a aussi nous, notre stand
sur les fleurs et les insectes.
C'est dimanche, ce dimanche et mardi,
toute la journée avec les scolaires.
Le rendez vous est donné
donc n'hésitez pas à venir au Champ
libre dès ce week end
pour rencontrer une partie de l'équipe.
Voilà, je vous remercie vraiment toutes
les deux d'être venu nous voir ce soir.
C'est des échanges qui ça passe vite 1 h.
Mais finalement,
on a pu aborder pas mal de choses.
Je vous remercie aussi, chers publics.
Toute l'équipe a la technique
et du café pour leur accueil.
Et puis nous,
on se retrouve le 2 novembre pour parler
cette fois de l'homme augmenté.
Fantasme ou réalité ?
Je vous laisse sur cette petite question
philosophique
et je vous souhaite à tous
une très bonne soirée.
Merci, merci beaucoup. On va.